and now it's time to actually present
the 2009 present
Street challenge Awards I do want to
thank all of our excellent speakers this
evening we're delighted that many
certificate recipients could be here
with us to be recognized for their
achievement but recognize that were it
not for the current economic situation
many more might have been able to
receive their certificates in person I'm
happy to be celebrating this year's
winning technologies with those who are
here and hope that you will convey the
spirit of tonight's celebration to those
of your colleagues who were not able to
attend this year's winners are important
because it's just these sorts of
technologies that will help create the
green economy that's vital to leading us
out of our current economic difficulties
and further towards sustainability the
first presentation is the word in the
academic category professor Christoph
mattia chef's key from Carnegie Mellon
University was selected for developing
atom transfer radical polymerization
which is a low-impact polymerization
technique that uses a copper catalyst
and environmentally-friendly reducing
agents and certificates are presented to
the following additional team members
who are here with us today from Carnegie
Mellon University Hong Chen dong
patricia goalless
way--check jakubowski
Patrick McCarthy
Richard McCullough
Laura Muller
Yun Zhong pick
johanna petracic
James spanswick
and Nick's are Rev ski
okay thank you very much
thank you all very much
you